this week I saw my faith in my favorite
major institutions betrayed first the
adult film industry stormy Daniels
a porn star giving a bad name to an
ancient trade in a nutshell she slept
with a guy who has money she signed a
deal not to talk about it then she lied
went public because she wanted even more
money even if he didn't want any more
store me yeah this is all about a
private deal between adults one who's
greedy enough to sink a presidency for a
few dollars more and one who likes women
a little too much yeah a rich guy
fooling around the media shrieks in
between their own flings and divorces
for those just tuning in from MSNBC a
porn star is someone who sleeps with
people for money and doesn't care who
knows it
Trump was just following directions on
the label
it doesn't seem like a big deal to me
especially when you're paying out of
your own pocket which requires wearing
pants but you know what that's not the
only institution that let me down how
about the law profession Davis Cohen and
a vanetti the stooge brothers Larry
Davis mo Cohen and curly what a law
office that would be I mean there must
be a flood because I'm seeing a lot of
dirtbags so now you can't trust adult
film stars and you can't even trust
lawyers next you're gonna tell me I
can't trust the natural Enquirer we need
a better class of people or lawyers it's
time for some legal heroes got a problem
that can only be solved by people who
have had years of experience in
dangerous situations need legal help but
also the utmost discretion
that call the offices of Terry Schappert
and Mike Baker one does a green beret
the other CIA shepherded Baker's I had a
nasty breakup with my ex and I took him
to court I never met Schappert and Baker
in person but they did get me back the
gold watch I gave to my ex last
Christmas it was still attached to his
arm
Shepherd and Baker got me my money fast
I asked for their address to cinema'
thank-you note but they told me if I
ever figured out their address I'd
already be dead Baker when I won my case
Sheppard and Baker wouldn't even take my
money they said they would take payment
in leather pants and just romantic you
pawns my neighbor Carl sued me because
my dog was barking too loud so I called
Schappert and Baker but then Carl
disappeared for ten years and hasn't
been seen since so I guess I didn't need
Shepherd a bit holy they killed Carl I'm
Shepard I'm Baker you don't need to call
a guy we are the guy well technically
guys
we are the guys were the guys so the
media right now is in the thrall of a
cheese fight among rats a bunch of
creeps grasping for money Fame and power
because of a pre-election erection a
private a private transaction based on
bedroom behavior among consenting adults
happening before the 2016 vote the media
drools but America yawns as I hear tales
of paid off performers I don't know I'm
not seeing victims hell I wish I got
paid for sex
seems like a win-win and the hypocrisy
of the press who pretend to be so
libertine now they're clutching their
pearls like oysters and a tornado they
pretend it's about infidelity when it's
really about impeachment to get rid of
someone they didn't approve of and the
Dems deny angling for impeachment but
like trying to hide a pot belly we see
it even under the muumuu so this story
is about as nothing as nothing can get
but to the media to everything because
nothing else is working to incite the
guy why because so far he's doing a good
job
longest bull market ever low
unemployment larger paychecks the media
can't understand that if only we could
help them out and now how to explain a
strong economy to the media by Sebastian
Gorka we're in a bull market the longest
one ever it's not a literal bull market
there aren't bulls in a store
it just means stocks are doing great how
easy is that to understand
is he listening to sort jazzing to in
gender studies courses new pathetic
nitwits unsightly
that was uncalled for we have the lowest
unemployment in decades that means more
people are working working at a thing
called jobs jobs are neat because you do
stuff that helps other people and
because you get a paycheck maybe one day
you should look at your paycheck and see
how much the government steals from him
and then he'll shut up about the greedy
rich you ignorant buckets of pointless
protoplasm well that was a bit harsh
apologies for that since Trump came into
office Patriots have gotten bigger it's
not just a piece of paper but actual
money which you can spend on things food
even or antiperspirant because you need
that badly smelly jerks oh dear there I
go again sorry anyway that's how you
explain a strong economy to the media
so things are so good you got to sniff
out something else and call it bad or
worse than Watergate it's time to
recognize that what we are watching in
the Trump presidency is worse than
Watergate what we're seeing now is more
dangerous than Watergate I've said
before that what we're seeing is worse
than Watergate so if everything is worse
than Watergate
maybe Watergate wasn't so bad that's
just me anyway why is the media so
breathless even when the country is
doing fine it's 3 R's revenge ratings
and Republicans they love the first two
they hate the third they can barely
contain the fury they have for Trump and
are willing to get rid of him even if it
tears the country apart and they also
have an audience for it just like they
did when their obsession first elected
Trump their last remaining idea
soul-destroying socialism is a century
old which is why they're willing to risk
economic hardship now all cuz Trump gave
them a big hurt inside he's their own
private appendix plus there is dumb as
Mallett's as always I ask what if the
media gets what they want and Trump goes
away what happens next
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
let's welcome tonight's guest he's so
tough he shaves with a wood chipper
retired Green Beret Master Sergeant
Terry Schappert and you might remember
him from previous standout performances
on this show I think it's I think it's
uh it's it's yeah yeah it's well okay
yeah and that's let me let me comment
which would see which actually was kind
of she said damsel who enjoys this dress
that's where you threw her Porter cat
Tim
[Applause]
he uses a steamroller to iron his shirt
former WWE Superstar my massive sidekick
Tyrus Terry you knew trump was gonna win
from the beginning every single week
they act like the events are the final
nail in the Trump's coffin
do you agree how do you view this by the
way that's pretty hard to follow yes
that was some excellent work did you
have legal problems where the guys are
talking and I'm not wearing any vinyl
pants because I'm not a performing
monkey okay I wear what I want when I
want
get to the quail case there's a question
yeah thanks oh look at you telling me
that so here's the thing and you know
absolutely Selena Zito is a great
reporter of her stuff and she has always
nailed this right oh it's a sleazy world
that we know it's there and and
everybody's involved in that but like
you said it's a results thing I know who
Trump was we all know who he was and
you're right they only in a country
that's so well fed so relatively safe
relatively safe so full of opportunity
and sort of easiness can this kind of
stuff bog people down and it really is
you said it meant it's about impeachment
they just they want so bad to get this
guy gone what are they gonna run on
mm-hmm the taxes are too low bring them
up yeah you know the VA is getting
better get rid of it I mean bring it
back let's make sure our enemies are our
friends again that kind of stuff they I
don't know what they're gonna run on
except this and you're right I I mean
maybe it says bad things about me but I
I kind of don't really care what Trump's
about anymore as long as he delivers on
what he said he was going to do and so
far he's not doing a bad job I know Mike
he remember it was always about
collusion now it's about copulation it's
like they went from how they went from
white Russians to sex on the beach
yeah well calculation to be fair does
involve collusion yes
look guys okay okay we can move on now
yeah you're right it was about collusion
but here's the thing the resistance they
don't give a crap about collusion with
Yesha they don't care
see ya keep track see went into my
answers keep going they don't give a
crap about kids being ripped apart from
families at the border that none of that
matter what it matters is to find a
hammer big enough to hit Trump into
submission yeah and and move towards
impeachment so all these things they
were just going to continue to look
that's why Muller is a perfect vehicle
for them because he's got an unlimited
budget an unlimited amount of time to do
his work and he's going to dig around
until he finds something that satisfies
this desire they've got every night they
go to bed hoping that when they wake up
in the morning sorry about that
I don't think you can say that on TV yep
okay but every night they go to bed at
night hoping that when they wake up
he'll be impeached yeah yeah what do you
think Kat
when people asked me about my political
views I'll often say that I'm fiscally
conservative and that I'm socially
liberal right because socially liberal
what that means is you don't give a what
other people do in their personal life
right yes and you know who seems to have
forgotten that is the liberal yes yeah
they forgot completely about what their
own ideology was supposed to even stand
for I'm not that old Greg no I'd like to
remind everyone of that I'm not that old
but I am old enough to remember when the
Democrats were screaming about how it
what a man does in his own bedroom is
his own business yeah
and I do believe that terms that they
just don't believe it anymore because
they're gonna try to take down Trump on
absolutely anything that they possibly
can just I don't I don't care that's
fine to know judges here I only like to
get upset about things that they affect
me personally and who Donald Trump has
or has not has had sex with has never
affected me no these are you right now
on the record I have not had sex
[Applause]
yeah go for good with that one you know
but you know we're talking about Tyrus
we're talking about victimless crimes
people that were paid off who are now
coming out of the woodwork because he
won if he hadn't won none of this would
have happened it's not even the point
listen if you have them any one of us
you me anyone in this crowd definitely
you if you put a T if you put a team
together we're gonna find something
wrong the other resources eventually
you're going to find something wrong
yeah somebody around us is gonna have
done something wrong yeah and this is no
the Russian thing here's we won't even
get to the Mueller investigation we
might not even get to that
yeah because unfortunately and this mr.
president has to own this a little bit
this is the only thing where I disagree
with him he hired the wrong people yeah
I'm straight up you surrounded yourself
with people you assumed we're gonna do a
job we were loyal and they were using
their your presidency for their own
means and some of it like metaphor is a
perfect example he worked for Ronald
Reagan I'm not into politics he worked
for Ronald Reagan
bring him on yeah yeah why not he's
probably a good pick then when they
found out he was a bet he left he was
gone they brought in Kellyanne Conway
they win the presidency the United
States yeah but instead of saying you
know what my bad and he can do this and
we understand this he had a good resume
I brought him in I'm not a politician I
found out he was wrong he had to go
we got Kellyanne and we're good yeah and
then he won't do it because of his fight
with this is where mr. president please
stop fighting with the press it's not
worth it if you came out and you said
listen I hire these people my bad
well we got it right yeah we got the
right people in no one here has a
problem
let's move on